let's talk about tattoos shall we
i know some of you here tonight have
probably got a sneaky little tattoo
hidden away
which means you're in the cool clip
don't worry the call club's not
exclusive you can join at any time
but what really springs into your mind
when i say the word tattoo
is it artistic expressive
beautiful
ugly intimidating just not for you
there's no wrong answers by the way
have you ever considered tattoos to be
empowering
or healing
tattoos are actually steeped in the
history of healy five thousand-year-old
ootsie the iceman was discovered with
markings tattooed on his limbs in areas
that would have been causing him chronic
pain
in cultures and tribes throughout
history and even in modern times symbols
are tattooed onto parts of the body to
alleviate symptoms of chronic illness
and it works
now whether you believe in juju
mind over matter healing a placebo
effect
or whether you consider this may
actually be a science not yet proven
there's something pretty special about
using tatting for healing
in our culture we focus more on
aesthetics don't we
but tattoos can still be very healing if
someone has a part of their body that
they don't like to show off
you put a tattoo that they really love
on there they are first on the nudist
beach in the summer every time
people use decorative tattoos to cover
scars
or
to signify a fresh start
or even to commemorate a loved one that
they may have lost and all of those
things can have
such a positive effect on someone's
mental health
but tattoos are not just for adornment
they also have a place in the medical
field
tattooing without pigment known as
microneedling dry needling collagen
induction therapy
can have an amazing effect on scar
tissue
it can
reduce tightness in a scar aiding
mobility it can
flatten a raised scar
and it can reduce the appearance of a
scar
we can even add skin tone pigment into a
scar to reduce the contrast between the
scar and the surrounding skin giving a
camouflaged effect
we can tattoo hair follicles to give a
bolding gentle shaved head look
or to add density to thinning hair which
is amazing for all genders
we can tattoo eyebrows
belly buttons toenails
we can improve the appearance of a cleft
lip we can separate webbed toes the
possibility is
endless tonight we're going to talk
about
areola restorative tattooing
this is where we fix or create an areola
and nipple complex
generally for people that have been
through some kind of surgery
there are many reasons as to why someone
would go through breast surgery but
tonight we're going to focus on breast
cancer
when somebody loses their breast to
cancer they have a mastectomy and they
choose to have a breast reconstruction
the majority of the time the nipples
don't make it
and when this happens
that person often doesn't connect with
their new breasts they don't have an
emotional attachment to it they just see
it as lumps of skin
and sometimes when you add a nipple and
areola complex to a reconstructed breast
it's like putting the cherry on the cake
it allows that person to feel a sense of
wholeness confidence
maybe even a little bit sexy and it's an
interesting phenomenon when you put a
nipple onto a breast that didn't have a
nipple all of a sudden
it's a bit taboo
but what happens
if that tattoo fades
does the empowerment fade
as well
i'm going to talk you through how i came
to the answer to that question
i started my tattoo apprenticeship in
2008.
i used the term apprenticeship very
loosely because there actually aren't
any formal qualifications in any kind of
tattooing and there aren't any
regulations regarding quality
so an apprenticeship in traditional body
art is work-based training you work
under master tattooers learning
everything that you need to know about
how to tattoo before you even ever do a
tattoo
the day i came to create my first tattoo
was the most terrifying day of my life
and the only thing i can liken it to
is like learning to drive
i'm guessing most of you sat in a car at
some point and a lot of us have sat in
cars our whole lives we've watched other
people drive they make it look really
easy some people can even multitask
while driving not recommended but they
can do it
and then when you get into that driver's
seat yourself for the first time
you suddenly realize you're in charge of
a death machine
you don't know which foot the brake
pedal is you don't know what gear you're
supposed to be and you're driving in the
middle of the road you're about to hit
your mates none on zebra crossing
everything feels like it's moving really
fast you must be doing 90 miles an hour
going at five miles an hour and there's
a queue of traffic behind you
that for me is what learning to tattoo
is like there are so many variables
you've got to think about your setup
your machine the person's skin the
person's pain threshold the list goes on
and it's very overwhelming
it takes most tattoo artists about three
years of full-time tattooing to reach a
point where
tattooing actually becomes
like second nature the same as driving
becomes second nature after a while
i was doing work-based training so i
always had support if i came across a
situation i didn't know how to overcome
i had someone to help me
which meant that nobody ever left me
with a really terrible tattoo
which is important
because as empowering as a great tattoo
can be
a bad tattoo can have a really negative
effect on someone's quality of life
if learning how to tattoo body art is
like learning to drive a car learning
how to do
medical tattooing on
damaged skin that's scarred or may have
been through radiation or had necrosis
would be like learning to drive an
arctic lorry
same basic skill set but
a lot more pressure and a lot more
knowledge needed
when i decided i wanted to move into
medical tattooing i went about my
learning in two ways
the first like most people that want to
learn anything i did a course
and the course i chose to do
was in areola micro pigmentation
this word micropigmentation is a little
bit misleading
it sounds very
clean doesn't it sounds professional
very suit and tie
i'm going to tell you a secret
it means tattoo
micropigmentation is the act of
implanting pigment into the dermis which
is the definition of a tattoo but it
sounds nicer doesn't it a bit less scary
the difference appears to come
in the fact that micropigmentation is
designed to fade
and it's really designed for the
tattooing of eyebrows lips and eyeliner
and it's designed to fade and facilitate
a regular top-up
and when it comes to permanent makeup
there are many reasons as to why that
would be important but one of which is
that fashions change
i'm not sure about you but my nipples
have never really been affected by
fashion
[Laughter]
these courses last about two to three
days and they're aimed at people that
already do micropigmentation so
permanent makeup artists
but they are also aimed at people that
have never even seen a tattoo machine
before such as people from the medical
field
which would be like teaching someone to
drive an arctic lorry in two days and
just handing them the keys without them
having ever driven a car wouldn't it
even after 10 years of tattooing body
art
my two days didn't fill me with
confidence i needed more knowledge
i chose to do a mentorship with a lady
called stacy ray weir
stacy ray is the founder of art which
stands for areola restrictive tattoo
and it's a global collective of highly
skilled restorative tattoo artists that
all work to a standard set by art
in an industry that has no standards a
standard that's high enough is really
important
art focuses on three main aspects
the first is experience
we can't
learn how to tattoo damaged skin until
we've mastered tattooing healthy skin
we have to learn how to do something
called reading the skin this is where we
can tell as we're tattooing how much
trauma we are causing when to change our
techniques that takes time that needs
experience
the second is realism
nipples are as unique as fingerprints
although not an alternative to
fingerprints
we have to have some artistic ability to
create something truly realistic that's
actually going to make someone feel
whole again
and the third is permanence
i have to be completely honest i didn't
really grasp how important permanence
was when it came to these tattoos until
i started doing them out in the big wide
world
people still come to me with these
really strange pink smudges where their
nipples should be and this is what's
left over from micropigmentation this is
the fading tattoo
i had one client
who had areolar micropigmentation
performed 12 years before she came to me
and she was so disappointed with the way
her breasts look with these strange pink
smudges that she hadn't shown anyone her
breasts in all that time not even her
husband
and now she feels so confident after i
um tattooed a realistic nipple and
areola complex for her that will last
forever
she is allowing me to show you the
picture tonight so that's how empowering
a tattoo can be
but
it did get me thinking
why aren't we talking about this
how many people are suffering in silence
it's not the kind of thing you talk
about down the pub is it all right then
how's your nipple doing we just don't
don't talk about it
[Laughter]
i wanted to give people a voice
so i put together a survey
and with the help of art and the nipple
innovation project we shared this survey
globally
and we asked people that had had
restrictive tattooing done of their
areola how they felt once it had healed
we already know from previous studies
and experience how amazing getting a
nipple tattoo can be for someone that
hasn't got a nipple
but we wanted to establish whether there
was a link between the healing of that
tattoo and how that person felt moving
forward
unsurprisingly the majority of people
that completed our survey had had
areolar micropigmentation done meaning
that their tattoo faded
of this group 81 admitted that they were
not satisfied with the healed
results 51 admitted that they had
suffered adverse mental health effects
due to the healing of their tattoos
there were a lot of really heartbreaking
comments on this survey
and the one that spoke to me the most is
that there is a lady
who keeps her bra on in the bus
because she hates the look of her breast
reconstruction so much because of her
faded nipple tattoos
imagine keeping your clothes on in the
bath just in case you catch glimpse of
yourself in the mirror
imagine being a surgeon that has spent
hours creating a really beautiful
symmetrical breast reconstruction to
have it aesthetically ruined by poor
nipple tattoos
i am a trustee for the nipple innovation
project
we are the uk's first tattoo cancer
charity
and our mission is to empower and
dignify breast cancer survivors with 3d
realistic permanent nipple tattoos
we have a directory of artists
throughout the uk that all work to a
standard set by nips another standard
very important
and funding is available from the
charity so that there is no financial
burden on the clients
our campaign for this year has been my
choice
true empowerment comes from making an
informed decision
we believe everybody should have access
to all of the knowledge that they need
to make this decision
some people were never told that their
tattoo was going to fade
some people found the idea of going back
to hospital every year for a topic too
traumatic
people should know that there is a safe
permanent alternative
we recently spoke at the oncology
convention at the nec which was a great
success
and one of the points that we were
really trying to make is that just
because someone's got funny coloured
hair and tattoos it draws on people with
electric crayons for a living
it doesn't mean that we're not
professional
it doesn't mean that we're not producing
quality results and it certainly doesn't
mean we don't care about our clients
long gone are the days of the backstreet
tattoo studio tattooing is actually a
pretty pretty uh upstanding career now
so there you go the word tattoo is not a
dirty word
it's a transformational word it's a
life-changing word
and when you give someone a tattoo that
truly makes them feel whole again and
gives them confidence and a better
quality of life
that my friends
is how you use tattoos as a tool for
empowerment
[Applause]